We like to think of precious works of art
as timeless. That da Vinci’s Mona Lisa will
smile for centuries to come, but what happens
when the march of time wears on and the colors
fade?
Well that’s when science steps in.
Hey guys Julia here for DNews
We like to think of art as a way to make ourselves
immortal. We’ll remember da Vinci’s name
because of the Last Supper, we’ll remember
Van Gogh in the bright yellow of his sunflowers.
But time is a cruel mistress, and so is moisture,
soot, and light. The effects of which dull
and damage priceless works of art.
So art restoration is as old as art itself.
As soon as the paint on Da Vinci’s The Last
Supper was dry it started to crack. And so
over the course of a few centuries, it’s
been repainted, glazed over, and touched up
numerous times. Many others famous works of
art, including “The View of Delft” by
Johannes Vermeer, have been retouched dozens
of times over the years. Sometimes the change
is a restoration, to preserve or fix a damaged
piece, other times a change is made to reflect
the changing times. So the art you seen in
a museum may have be touched by more than
a few hands.
But that’s part of the problem, art restorations
that seemed like a good idea at the time,
turned out to be disasters when new information
is revealed years later. According to Yale
Scientific “Old conservation manuals suggested
covering the entire painting in wood-ash and
then wiping it off with water, a process that
caused an extremely alkaline substance harmful
to the painting to form.”
So the standby of restoration nowadays is
to “ ‘ensure that you do no harm to the
work, and that wherever possible anything
you do could be reversed by a later generation’.”
In some cases the passage of time means the
accumulation of dirt and grime, as seen with
the Sistine Chapel which underwent a massive
restoration that began in the late 1980s.
The solvent, called AB-57, is made of bicarbonate
of sodium and ammonium and carefully applied
by brush. After sitting for a few minutes,
it would be wiped away along with any grime
and layer of glue. That layer of glue is a
matter of some controversy.
Some historians claim it was Michelangelo's
doing, other’s claim it was a disastrous
restoration made years later. It’s hard
to tell what Michelangelo’s original intent
was. It’s not like there were photographs
back then, conservationists had to rely on
what people were writing about when the frescoes
were first displayed.
And that’s one of the hard things to know
about art that’s been around for awhile.
Is it grime or varnish or pigments put there
by the painter?
Luckily with modern science, conservationists
can figure out some of the answers without
destroying priceless works of art.
Great art should always see the light of day,
but sometimes the light is the cause of the
art’s demise in a process called photodegradation.
Basically the energy from light, especially
UV light causes the chemical bonds in dyes
to break. This essentially makes the colors
fade.
Which is one of the reasons you’re not allowed
to use flash photography in a museum.
But light can be a solution too. Many restoration
attempts start with an x-ray or infrared imaging.
Infrared imaging works by detecting all of
the wavelengths of light that the painting
absorbs and reflects, which is more than the
human eye can see. Some of these infrared
wavelengths penetrate deeper than visible
light. By getting past the paint, these infrared
wavelengths can see other layers of the work,
revealing underdrawings and previous versions
of the work. Which can help tell restorers
about the artist's original intent.
Like one recent analysis by Engineer Pascal
Cotte revealed that da Vinci changed in his
mind. A lot. One painting, Lady with an Ermine
went through three different versions before
he decided on the iconic white ermine we know
today. The painting was analyzed by a new
technique called Layer Amplification Method
(LAM) pioneered by Cotte himself. The technique
uses intense pulses of light to see between
the layers of paint.
Cotte told the BBC that with this technique
"We've discovered that Leonardo is always
changing his mind, "This is someone who hesitates
- he erases things, he adds things, he changes
his mind again and again."
Just as light can damage and even reveal art,
light can even breathe life into old work.
Until the late 1970s, Harvard University had
murals by famous painter Mark Rothko hanging
in their cafeteria. Not surprisingly after
years of damage from light and college kids,
the paintings went into storage. When they
reemerged in 2014, the paintings were badly
faded. Rather than turn to traditional restoration
methods, Harvard turned toward technology.
After finding the original colors from old
photographs and other paintings, a computational
photographer from MIT Ramesh Raskar, designed
an algorithm to match the old colors. Then
those colors were beamed at the paintings
from wall mounted projectors. It produced
the illusion that the murals were as bright
as the day they were painted.
As for da Vinci's most iconic piece, the Last
Supper thanks to centuries of wear, bombing,
and poor fresco experimentation, it will never
again return to its former glory. But maybe
technology can bring it back to life in a
way. In 2012, a group scientists from Leonardo3,
a Milan based museum, digitally restored the
painting. Without laying a finger on the fragile
fresco they reconstructed it through high
definition photographs. Painstakingly reimagined
in pixels rather than pigments, the new digital
version revealed details like a salt shaker
that appears to have been knocked over by
Judas and maybe even a shadow of the artist
himself.
Leonardo da Vinci was a Renaissance man. In
his time there were no clear boundaries between
the arts and the sciences, it was all within
the pursuit of knowledge. He might have found
math as eloquent and beautiful as any of his
masterpieces. Mathematician Tara Long discusses
a study that shows how math can be perceived
as a beautiful piece of art in the brain in
this video right here.
So what do you think?
Should art be restored if it’s damaged?
Or should the passing of time be included
in how we see a piece?
Sound off down in the comments below….